you
[Music]
so I appreciate the bit of history
because this talk is gonna start with a
story going all the way back to the day
the year 2012 this time when I was a
graduate student I was programming a lot
and like a lot of people that program I
spent a lot of time on Stack Overflow so
there was a time that I ran into a
question on Stack Overflow that hadn't
been answered it was a Python question
and I realized that I was able to answer
it so that was the first question
answered on Stack Overflow and I found
in the years afterwards I was doing my
PhD work I was writing some papers and I
was teaching but I was also answering
some questions on Stack Overflow
I discovered a couple years later that
one answer I left turned out to have a
rather large impact on my life so as I
asked about let me see 450 Python
questions and 40 50 are questions and
one question about statistics which was
what is the intuition behind the beta
distribution this is a question I saw
and I realized I had been given an
answer to this individually in a couple
of courses that I'd taught and people
that I'd talked to and this was a chance
to make it public so I wrote an answer
in response about comparing the beta
distribution and Ben baseball statistics
and I found a couple years later an
engineer at Stack Overflow the same
company I was that I was answering these
questions on discovered this question
when he wasn't working on improving a be
testing so he ended up tweeting about
that answer and then he followed it
shortly with I don't know how to enjoy
and your PhD but if you want an
interview here you can have one so a
couple of weeks later I interviewed with
him and that was my first data science
job at Stack Overflow I later learned
the conversation that had gone on
internally was the effect of wow what if
we just hired that guy
[Applause]
this is what I call a freak accident
it's not something I would necessarily
want to learn too much from I tell the
full story in my blog post one year as a
data scientist Stack Overflow but it is
something that has profoundly affected
my philosophy around public work see
when I was in graduate school I thought
of my goals like this I thought well I'm
gonna start with an idea and that's just
the beginning then I'm going to start
working on it get some preliminary
results then I'm gonna draft a
manuscript and it'll be I'll be most of
the way there I'll complete the
manuscript and finally one day I'll have
a valuable published paper what I
realized is I should have been thinking
of my goals a little differently
anything still on your computer is to a
first approximation useless it's never
it's not going to be shared it's not
going to be used by anyone else and when
I look back at grad school the things I
did that that ended up not being
publicized in the state of my computer
even I had forgotten them but is there
as anything out in the world it could be
a published paper it could be a product
like a web product it could be a blog
source it could be an open source
contribution or it could be as small as
a tweet all of those are way more
valuable than anything that you didn't
share so fundamentally this is a I say
to talk about public work but it's
really a talk without sharing it's talk
about taking what we have and what we've
gotten good at taking our skills and
then sharing them with
other people ticular I'm going to walk
through a few types of sharing that I
think are incredibly effective
everywhere everywhere from blogging to
writing a book I know I can share my
observation that no matter where you are
in your career these are probably
helpful though each of these media
probably comes more helpful at later
stages of your career so I'll start at
areas where even if you're if you're a
undergraduate student or an aspiring
data scientist you can you can still get
into some of these media like blog and
tweet blogging and tweeting and if
you're someone with a lot of experience
and expertise some other technologies
that you could use to share your work so
I'll give three reasons for spending
time in public work and they're gonna
keep reappearing throughout this talk
the first is to advance your career
really to build a public portfolio of
your work and let other people know
about your skills it led to a job for me
but it could but it's also led to other
opportunities and many other things that
wouldn't have happened if I hadn't been
sharing my work publicly certainly this
keynote wouldn't have happened if I just
been working without without sharing
anything that I did online
another is practicing good habits I find
that public work builds particular kinds
of habits that you wouldn't build if you
were or at least more effective than you
build them you're working within one
company one team or just on your own
I'll go through a few examples
and finally you it helps you contribute
to the community there's selfless
reasons that we want or that we want to
share public work to make sure that
everything that we build other people
can use disclaimer
one is that as I've already described my
own job story a lot of this talk is what
worked for me that means we need an
obligatory xkcd about survivorship bias
the fact is the kinds of we duty to
observe that if I talk about just what
had been working for me and and my
particular successes maybe you don't see
people that try that and it didn't work
for them I think it's very much worth
keeping in mind and may be taken with a
grain of salt but I'd also say that I've
seen a lot of people who have had a lot
of success by sharing their work online
in a lot of and and throughout this talk
I'm going to share particular examples
of other people who move through
blogging or tweeting or other types of
public work made a difference for
themselves into that community
the second disclaimer is that this title
is called the unreasonable effectiveness
of public work not the unreasonable
necessity of public work there are other
ways succeed and there are other ways to
have a really fulfilling career so if
you're someone if some people just
aren't going to have the time to be the
ability or the or the interest in doing
public work but I'd like to convince as
many people as possible that might that
it might be interesting for you so let
me start with blogging why start a blog
well you see a couple of reasons a one
of the most important is building a
public portfolio if you're someone in
early in your career who might start and
do a job interviews a blog is not just a
great way to get employers to hear about
you it's a way to put your best foot
forward you can take whatever kinds of
analyses you're most interested in doing
whatever skills you're interested in
showcasing and put them online so that
other people can use that use that to
understand what you'd bring to a company
another is that blogging is an
incredibly effective way to practice
writing visualization and other kinds of
communication in housing and garrick
relevant will in this book are for data
science they talk about the importance
of communication within the data science
workflow and it's it can be often be
hard to practice communication within a
typical data science pattern sometimes
sometimes it's hard to fit into a usual
job and blogging is all about what
visualizations can they create what how
can i structure my argument how can i
structure these points and I've found
that blogging has been one of the ways
that most improved my own writing skill
third is that it's a way to teach or
give advice in a way that scale is a way
to change the community for the better
by thousands of people at a time so I've
shared a thought that when you've
written the same code three times write
a function when you're given the same in
person advice three times or at a blog
post so the reasons for writing a blog
post are sim
for the reasons we'd write a functioning
code to avoid constant reuse how often
do you find yourself in a conversation
maybe at this conference where you say
to someone oh I have very strong
opinions on that let me try and walk you
through them and you meet someone else
you walk them through those opinions as
well if you have a blog post that's the
opportunity for thousands or tens of
thousands of people to read that opinion
and anytime you in the future you might
want to change someone someone's mind
you can point them towards that so how
do you start a blog is the extraordinary
blog down packaged by E way shape as
well as I'm amber Thomas and Alison Hill
who wrote the the blog down book about
creating a websites with our markdown so
if you've used our markdown for creating
reports you can now use one file one
market on file for each post in a blog
as a really fantastic guide towards
starting your own and it's one that lets
you integrate our terms were from our
directly to code results and figures in
your blog posts I give a lot more advice
in terms of how I can start a blog in
naturally my blog post advice to
aspiring data scientists start a blog
which I'm now pointing all of you
towards and thereby thereby proving my
points one of the points that I make in
this blog post is that it can be very
difficult to it can feel like you're
screaming into the void when you first
publish publish online if you don't
already have people that are following
you so my recommendation is if you start
a data related blog tweet me a link and
I'll tweet about your first post and the
year-plus since I made that offer I've
had the real privilege to get to to
retweet and tweet about a lot of
people's work a lot of people from all
over the spectrum of a data science
career I'll share a couple examples of
those in a moment so if you're wondering
what could I blog about the place I'd
always start is analyzing a data set
I've missed the bread-and-butter of data
science blogging as I've opened I've
created a new post I'm going to start
with the data set I'm going to share
some things that I learned and for that
I think one of the most remarkable
projects that enables that is tied a
Tuesday run by the RF for data science
online learning community so this each
week heidi tuesday releases a new day
every every Monday and then on Tuesday
the community generally discusses it
shares the shares the results so a
fantastic approach to starting a blog is
go to tidy Tuesday find the latest data
set we have an older one that you're
interested in share what you can learn
from it I think there's a lot of data
sets you can use though and I want to
highlight an example of someone who did
it to remarkable effect one of the
people who shared their blogpost with me
was Jeff Cao who was at the time and
aspiring data scientist at the Metis
boot camp and he wrote an article
discovering that more than a million net
neutrality comments were likely faked
he'd used a natural language processing
to discover enough repetition in these
comments be sure they were created by
BOTS and that actually got a national
news coverage and a really a lot of
really notable um attention so one good
place for looking for analyzing data
might be current events but that you're
interested in and have a data-driven
perspective to add another good really
good place to look for blog entries is
if you're an academic for every paper
turning it into a blog post post this is
a great advice from Philip Kuo where he
shares that everything after his PhD
he's taken a he's thinking each of the
papers turn it into a blog post and
encourages students to do the same
because 10 to 100 more people will read
blog posts than read a published paper
so peer review papers have a very
important part of the public work
ecosystem but they're very well
complemented by blog posts another great
thing to use is viewing a blog posts
that teach a concept so Muhammad was a
aspiring data scientist who share this
post with me I was a really excellent
look through some topics that he'd been
learning about performance metrics for
machine learning so as he was learning
these concepts as he was taking classes
and and mastering these skills he was
also publishing this work online when I
when I talk to people that are taking
data camp courses and are learning to
become data scientists and they're
asking me what's next that's almost
always my advice to try right at
creating blog posts where they share
what they've learned
here's another fantastic example of
teaching a Khan
this is a blog post by Heather and
Jaclyn olace about creating api's in our
so this is it with a kind of total of
tutorial where you include code
sometimes backing it up with some open
source work and therefore enable lots of
people to be able to take the same
approach if you want to see loads of
examples of people everywhere from its
aspiring data scientist to expert who
asked me to tweet about their blog post
you can check out the data blog hashtag
on Twitter like I said it's been really
inspiring speaking of Twitter the next
kind of medium that I would recommend
sharing your work in is to is Twitter
who here has a Twitter account let's say
an active Twitter account that's what I
like to see I think probably at least
half it's really exciting critters is a
short form medium that means it's not
necessarily where you'd publish your
work in the first place but it's an
amazing place to promote and discuss
your work so each time I come out with a
blog post I generally share share it on
Twitter along with a graph from it and
point people towards it this is a good
way to start discussion get some
comments get some aah get some other
opinions but it doesn't have to be your
own work you know is also a fantastic
way to promote the work of others so
mera average this is a really fantastic
example from our average we're in
December we decided to run a dev the
advent calendar where every day she
highlighted another data scientist and
some of their work so this was a
fantastic way to you to use this
platform of sharing sharing to better
strengths in the community and promote
some people so the so Mara is certainly
if you follow one person in in the
Twitter our world certainly follow her
it's also an amazing place to analyze
data sets with the community so I
already mentioned that I a Tuesday
project once you once people have
finished analyzing add a week's dataset
they can take that data set publish it
and discuss it and share it on Twitter
and there are a few accounts like the R
for D s community account will generally
retweet it so if you're worried I'm
doing an analysis is anyone going to see
it or or is anyone going to think this
is a topic worth analyzing this is a
really fantastic place to start
another great example is sharing what
you've learned at a conference who's
been live tweeting this conference
solid-solid yeah so the UM so I'm gonna
share my favorite example of someone
live tweeting our studio cough who's a
Brooke Watson Brookes been doing these
amazing posts where she takes notes
there's a drawing of a speaker and then
shares shares it online so this is a
definitely another fantastic person to
follow but there's lots of other
creative ways to share what your share
the talks are you've seen take a picture
of a slide share some share some
something you've learned a particular
funny joke and that someone else the
Twitter is really useful I think it's
especially amazing because we have to
remembered not everyone is going to this
conference maybe people that aren't even
watching the streaming of it they still
have the opportunity to learn something
from it finally just because Twitter is
a short forum medium doesn't mean you
can't share work on it here's a great
example from Paige Bailey I who's at
Google who shares the sets of code and
then visualizations that come from it so
this happens right after Twitter got 20
80 characters and this started being a
little more possible so it's a really
good place to share I'm share an example
of code on our tip maybe just a link to
a really good data set something that is
useful in itself as we'll see later I
think there's a lot of relationship
between being being able to communicate
well in a short form like this and being
able to work in longer form media so in
fact I'm more something I discover is
that sometimes if you have a really
short post it could even the fastest
thing you do because sometimes
unfortunately could be much more popular
than anything you put a lot more time in
tow so move on to the next area this is
something that once you've gotten a
little bit of comfort at least you have
you have some comfort programming in are
you certainly don't have to be an expert
but um but once you're ready an amazing
point is to contribute to open source so
this is a slide from Mara Avex talk
contributing to tie diverse packages
that points out the motivation for open
source is that it helps
yourself and the larger community so
when you find that something you're
working on if that's an amazing time
that you generally find useful that's an
amazing time to turn it open source and
the reason it's so helpful is that when
you contribute to the community you'll
find the community contributes back so
this was an example of some code that I
wrote while I was in graduate school
that I discovered that I often work with
a linear model I'd want to turn the
coefficients into a data frame so I had
this code and I was finding it pretty
useful for a few different problems I
was working on I decided to release the
open-source packaged room so I ended up
promoting on Twitter as described before
it's a great way to share share projects
like this and I found within the
following years it did bill it has
gotten more than 200 pull requests other
people improving this package it's now
groans last year in fact it was taken
over by Alex Hayes as a full-time
maintainer so this project has gotten so
much bigger than I could have ever built
thanks to the fact that I was able to
share it online
this kind of contribution could start
just with a pull request so here's a
great article from Nick crane on 10
steps to becoming a tie diverse
contributor so this is a examples of how
you can go into a cut into Patti verse
packages discover some some issues that
need resolving and help out it could be
a bug fix it could be a new feature it
could be as simple as a typo but it's a
great way to start working an open
source I think a particularly good
initiative done by some toddy verse
packages including Alex Hayes on the
prune package is to create a list of
beginner-friendly issues these are
issues that would say if you're just
around github try going to this list
finding one that you can approach and
work your way up from there if you're
somewhat more comfortable it's a great
time to create a package who here has
created another package nice who's
published it on github on cran still
pretty fantastic yeah
creating a package is an amazing way to
get a lot of people to use your code but
it's also a great way to practice skills
and documentation unit testing and
creating intuitive user interfaces so
you could have a lot of experience
coding for yourself on your own projects
but you'll still be missing the kinds of
practice that open-source provides we
are writing code designed for other
people so have these book our packages
fantastic resource for learning Berlin
all the way from creating the code to
writing the tests and documentation and
publishing on cran moving on to the next
recommendation is to us to give talks so
why should you give a conference talk
well you're all listening to me and now
on show but seriously consider all the
amazing things we've learned at this
conference it's the last two days these
are a few of the amazing talks I've been
to I learned a lot about shiny I learned
a lot about teaching I learned about GG
animated learned about RNA pea eyes I
learned what they were being done in the
ACLU and this this is a kind of
confidence and opportunity to share what
you're working on conference isn't a
tutorial it's not a resource it's not an
opportunity to go in front of people and
make sure you change everything about
them it's not a chance to take all your
expertise and put it in it's a sales
pitch it's an opportunity to convince
people that something is worth looking
into some great advice for giving a data
science talk comes from my sister
Emily's blog post given your first data
science talk some of the useful
recommendations that she adds
include that you should imagine giving
the talk to yourself from three to six
months ago so if you're thinking I don't
have anything I want to talk about think
what do I know that six months ago I
wish I'd known and then try turning that
into a talk another important aspect is
to practice giving the talk out loud
it's even better if you can practice
giving it to other people but even just
giving it to yourself out loud lets you
notice we're transitions might be
awkward and finally she recommends you
should not rely on bullet points
oops sorry Emily you might think
talking's not for you you might say what
if I'm an introvert well there's some
really useful advice is here from Kevin
Goldsmith which is one of the reasons
speaking at conferences great is it
makes networking a lot easier people
know who you are and have something to
talk to you about so a recommendation
for introverts is to try becoming
speakers I should know I'm an introvert
myself and now I have something to talk
to you all about if you're still nervous
emily has some great advice because
imagine that your audience uses p-values
of 0.25 for significance there are a lot
of fantastic places that you can speak
some of them include local meetups so
those you can find those often and
Meetup the are ladies organization is a
global organization that promotes gender
diversity within the art community and
has meetups all around the world and
here's a list of more than 350 our
conferences and meetings that were
written in all kinds of countries it's
really worth examining so you can find a
local meetup and give a talk there but
you can also give a talk at a larger
conference like this one often that's a
chance to eat your larger audience and
also a chance to network with the larger
our community when I've given talks at
conferences like these it's been really
fantastic to meet people that are
working on similar problems and I'm
interested in talking to me about them
finally just because you're giving a
talk doesn't doesn't necessarily qualify
as public work unless there's a
permanent artifact this is something to
really avoid is that um is if you give a
talk you feel like you've got it out
there into the world but you never share
it online that makes it fundamentally
ephemeral you want to make sure you
publish your slides you can find this
talk at this link I'll be sharing it on
Twitter afterwards as well and Karl
Grauman's been doing a great service
during this conference of keeping a list
of links to slides from the conference
on github so as people are giving their
talks a tour afterwards if you missed
the talk or if you wanted to review
something or visit a link from a talk
go into a little deeper these slides are
a really critical resource this next
media of public work is one that I only
became familiar with and started really
thinking about in the last few months
but it's one that I'm really excited
about particular recording screencasts
so this was a example of screencast
where I've been taking tiny Tuesday
datasets each week and opening them
without ever having looked at the data
before going into them may exploring it
making graphs draw trying siskel models
thinking about my conclusions for about
an hour without ever having seen the
data before so I found this a really
exciting way to to teach and and
generally narrowed my process and share
it particularly because it takes minimal
preparation in a fixed time window so if
I said if I I want to point in my career
where it can be difficult to schedule a
lot of time to write but I can always
schedule an hour and a half to set up
and record a screencast it's also really
great for letting you teach tricks that
you wouldn't have thought of teaching so
for example I use functions from the for
cat's package for working with factors a
lot during these analyses and I
discovered that I think that a lot of
viewers I hadn't necessarily thought let
me go teach the for cats package but
people watching them pick up on these
tricks and these small different small
things that they can do in are other
things like the style of how in May of
how I assign a name objects or tricks
like doing it like manipulating
variables something group by again these
are things that I wouldn't write a blog
post or tweet about I wouldn't think of
making it a tip but get to fit within a
screencast a limitation of screencast is
that you need to be pretty capable and
confident enough to improvise your way
through a screencast this isn't because
it'll stop you from making mistakes you
will make mistakes it's about being
comfortable enough and embarrassing
yourself sometimes so for example I've
in one screencast I find myself crash in
our studio four times in an hour in
another I forgot about that lubricates
mdy function I found
rewriting it from scratch and in the
moat part of the most embarrassing one I
started using GG animate and realized I
didn't know how to use the new version
which since I was the one who had
published the initial version is a
little bit embarrassing so I this is
something I don't know a lot of people
who are doing screencasts of encouraging
some people I know to try out the format
one person who's doing a great job it is
Rachel Chapman from Kaggle who doesn't
just do screencast she does live coding
on kana twitch so that's something I've
thought about is should I try doing the
coding live people can ask questions can
try and respond to feedback they can
point out the mdy function to me it's on
so I'm really excited to see where I'm
where screencasts might let go in the
future as a medium of teaching finally I
shared this advice before when you're
rid of the same code three times write a
function we've written the same in
person advice three times
write a blog post or as Hadley advises
try writing a book so writing a book is
generally something that you'd want to
be more advanced in a career I imagine
who here has written a book ebooks count
as long as you feel like they're
finished between the book let's get a
round of applause I guess
who thinks they plan to write a book
sometime in their career I'd encourage
everyone to think about think about it
seriously because I'm wearing a book can
seem somewhat intimidating but it really
fits as part of a continuum with a lot
of these other media of communication I
think to write a book the two things you
need are a good amount to say so you
need to be a little further in your
career enough to have a lot of advice we
want to give beyond a technical or
professional topic I'm going to have to
have some practice and saying it in that
second part the practice is say in
communicating is what all of this public
work has been about so we we talked
about short form communication like a
tweet so in a tweet I might be able to
do this is a small bit of um of our code
that it's designed to demonstrate a
concept of updating a beta distribution
it's enough to fit in a tweet and then
there's a medium form communication and
this can be everything from blog posts
to package documentation like vignettes
and building more practice built um
rendering this kind of writing helps
once you get to long-form documentation
so this is so in this case I took a
series of blog posts that I'd written
each teaching concepts around empirical
Bayes estimation and turn them into an
ebook introduction to empirical Bayes so
another a great example of taking public
work and building on it to create a book
from julius silky so julia started by
were by um doing some blog posts about
natural language processing particularly
sentiment analysis on Jane Austen novels
so she does a really fantastic blog and
I was invited to our to our open side
hackathon where I met where she met me
and we together built the tidy tax
package she moved from making a service
uber did Bob post vention - maintain an
open-source package she followed this up
with more blog posts that explore
explained the philosophy of the package
how on how to use it as well as a
sequence of vignettes that go with the
package that are medium form
documentation and in 2017 we turned that
into a book text mining with are
available wherever books are sold as
at that link you notice how I plugged my
two books two slides in a row
take notes kids how do you write a book
well luckily you way is on the case
because there's a book down package so
just as blog down allowed each RMD file
to be one blog post book town has one
RMD for each chapter and book down
handles the the enormous amount of
formatting headaches and the middie
Gritty of references and of um and
indexes and all these problems and
really turns that on it handles it for
you so you can write some focus on the
content and write something awesome i
found when i'm working with with book
down it feels more like I'm writing a
sequence of blog posts than like I'm
then as if I have an enormous book that
I have to contend with in fact all the
books that I have described during this
talk all were developed in book down so
why work publicly earlier I showed this
slide and I I'm somewhat aggressive when
I say work that's still on your computer
is useless of course it's not useless it
could be something that you that you're
working on within your company it could
be something that's helping you with in
your life but why do I say it's so
important to share your work well
imagine if nobody did I threw out this
entire series of slides I've been
highlighting a lot of people that have
done great examples of public work as
well as people that have create have
shared guidelines and resources and
tutorials
they'll help other people do public work
and every time along the way I've been
publishing I've been putting the link on
the bottom right so that afterwards you
can go through and try some of these
resources yourself can you imagine if
these hadn't been made public would've
had to call my talk the unreasonable
effectiveness of keeping stuff in your
computer Lydia would have watched it it
would have had slides like my friend
Bill did something cool and he just told
me about it at lunch last week and said
maybe I'll publish it someday think
about those conversations you have think
about when you say when you talk to
someone you say oh I've got something
really cool I've been working on I've
got this I realized this interesting
thing about mushy about this machine
learning method or I've been
I found a really cool dataset if you
never published it where is it um
where's that end up can you say my
colleague Rachel made a great graph she
showed it to me to me on her computer I
wish you'd been there
they say that 80% of success is showing
up
and similarly I'd say to some extent 80%
of success within public work is getting
your work out there so whatever you have
I really recommend thinking through
these approaches and sharing your work
thank you
[Applause]
okay I certainly hope that we have the
fun throwable mics may be out there but
we have definitely some time for some
questions for David and then again as
promised we'll have a break and I'll
tell you some time when the panel will
start
I see things being thrown so that we you
know when all right so I see a hand here
it's a little difficult with the lights
and the fact that I can't see very well
sorry sure look this helps so we're
right in the middle bar
yeah burgundy shirt
hi look I was gonna ask one of the
things that I think could be really hard
if you're trying to write blog post
about data science especially if you're
sort of throwing it out into the void is
getting sort of like editing advice or
maybe like any kind of feedback on your
post before or what it's sort of like if
draft form is there any kind of way the
art community we can sort of support
that I think that's a really interesting
question I generally recommend when you
read in your first few posts and maybe
you're not sure you could use some
feedback still getting them out into the
world there's there are communities
generally I've found it very welcoming
and is a good place where people can
give some some feedback but I think
that's the kind of initiative I also
think you certainly certainly go to your
local communities so if you're when I
was in grad school my lab mates and my
adviser were fantastic resources your
your manager or colleagues are also
great resources I think it's the kind of
thing that's probably worth formalizing
in some kind of program and I'm not sure
I don't know much about it I don't have
anyone that's tried that but like um I
don't know feedback Fridays feedback
Fridays you're here heard it here first
let's go to Reina cool this is working
awesome yeah my name is erina Harris
does a beautiful talk thank you what the
one thing you said you need to have
advice and experience to write a book so
what's maybe the harm and writing a book
too soon I don't think I've ever found a
case with someone wrote a book too soon
one of the reasons and I'm so
encouraging throughout the book of of
doing public work is I think it's very
rare that people fall on the side of
publishing too often obviously they're
exceptions like data breaches and such
but I don't find that people say are
writing too many blog posts analyzing
data when they're too early in their
career it's almost certainly the other
direction I think the risk of writing a
book too early is that you wouldn't have
is you would have enough to fill it I
think the kinds of the kinds of people I
find once you start when you want to
write a book it's generally kind of
people that could fill up a university
course with material that might even be
a little bit too much but could
certainly give a long talk and give
maybe a two-day workshop I can think of
enough fast to the problem where they'd
want to give useful advice I
particularly think in this sense about
both technical and professional like
help advice I think if I imagine myself
trying to write a book in two and when I
let's say just started grad school I
feel like I would I would run out of
things to say but yeah I think one thing
I found is I keep learning to people
that have that have published books
before they started the PhD or during
their PhD it's really not a thing that
has a hard age or career cutoff so I'd
really recommend to thinking in terms if
you write out if you say write a lot of
blog posts how they can be linked
together into long-form documentation
thanks for the presentation do you do
you have any opinion on the importance
of updating all the blog posts versus
investing in writing new ones I know
it's not sexy but yes I'd say never do
it I'll tell you why you never update or
blog posts because if you do it stops
you from writing future ones it not
simply because you're spending time you
could be publishing the new ones I would
say it's because it's because when you
write a blog post one of the
amazing things about it is that it gets
to be done we call it the cult of done
is there's a popular description of this
so obviously should fix like like errors
or other problems in old blog posts but
if you find yourself treating a blog
post as a resource that has to be
maintained for example going if I went
back to my I think I have a very old
blog post that uses data dot table if I
went back and used the apply are if I
went back and fixed the various kings
that have broken thanks to have new did
you deploy our releases that would mean
every new blog post that I wrote would
become an obligation and I and that
would discourage me from publishing them
in the first place so it's a bit of an
extreme answer but I'd actually say um I
would not prioritize that very heavily
with clear exceptions such as um if you
have if you've someone find something
truly wrong in it or dangerous or other
things like that yeah I'd say put it out
there and let it be done working the
next thing I'm I'm pretty I think I see
who has this this alright thanks David I
have a really important question for you
did I pay you to promote the two books
was that an option all right the real
question so I actually have a problem
with tweeting which is the discover
discoverability I mean many times I see
you like there are very there are
excellent tweets sharing like excellent
ideas but I feel like if I miss it if
there means such a treat if I feel is
just like gone forever so do you think
that is a problem and if you do how
would you solve that yeah I would say
the advantages of Twitter are very
ephemeral it's very much during during
this conference see everything that's
happening it's not a great an ideal way
to crystallize knowledge for future use
it's not the way a blog post or
especially a book would be having said
that there are a few ways that it makes
things permanent that I really enjoy so
if you haven't tried this you should try
I'm not gonna do it on my computer but
you could go to Twitter and do from :
than their name a user name and search
only within one person's tweets so if
you know oh I said something once or
Emily said something or um or I want to
find it a tweet with Jenny shared this
really good piece of advice you can
search just within one person's tweets
one way that I use that is for finding
my own conference tweets so I treat
during a conference I generally treat
Twitter as a public diary I'm not very
good at note-taking so instead I live
tweet each of the talks with what I find
most important and afterwards I can go
back and discover the the things that I
wanted to share so throughout this talk
I've been going I'd do include a couple
few of my old tweets and I did find them
in this way so I think we should take
one more question then we'll have our
break in the panel so if we already
given out the mic okay yeah can you all
hear me no yeah so I think after hearing
you talk we all seem very motivated to
write blog posts but how would you
recommend that people stay like keep the
momentum and continually publish blog
posts not just like after this
conference right now but maybe in like
three months six months even a year you
know when I started my blog it was
late 2014 and there's around the time
also that I felt it started the broom
package and they waited a few months and
I wrote for blog posts because I knew
that once the blog was up I assumed I'd
be out of ideas and I could never blog
again so I 1/2 for saved up that I could
publish and every single time I've get
published in a blog post since then I've
thought yep this is the last one I'm out
of ideas
what I'd say is the best way to keep
motivated is to start that feedback loop
is once you put ideas out in the world
people are you get you get feedback on
them you get people excited about them
you get compliments on them sometimes
you get recognized and these are ways
that that build your own excitement and
keep you motivated to keep doing work
online so I'd say there isn't there
isn't there isn't a shortcut to starting
and put it and putting your work online
you
[Music]